[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 3 juin très heureux
de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de ce set 8
journal jusqu'au 9 juin ce sont les
journées nationales contre la leucémie
elle vise à sensibiliser le public à la
maladie à lever des fonds pour la
recherche médicale
la leucémie touche 9000 personnes par an
en france dont plus de 9 % d'enfants et
d'adolescents
j - 4 avant le début de la coupe du
monde féminine de football s'est en
france les bleus affrontent vendredi la
corée du sud un match d'ouverture qui se
prépare en ce moment à clairefontaine en
yvelines ce matin l'entraînement des
joueurs tricolores étaient ouverts au
public
et puis ça ne vous a pas échappé le
soleil et la chaleur étaient de retour
ce week-end dans les yvelines avec des
températures au delà de 30 degrés
certains en ont profité pour se
rafraîchir avec des jeux d'eau proposé à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines et des représentants également
du groupe local de greenpeace versailles
seront sur ce plateau nous parlerons
avec eux de la question de la gestion
des déchets nucléaires
une semaine après la déblâcle la débâcle
aux élections européennes des
républicains laurent wauquiez
démissionne de la présidence du parti
il a annoncé hier soir dans le 20h de
tf1 de nombreux élus du mouvement et de
droite avait demandé son départ après le
résultat de ce scrutin et l'air a obtenu
8,48 % des voix soit son plus mauvais
score dans une élection nationale
après cette démission la réaction de
plusieurs yvelinois valérie pécresse
salue la décision de laurent wauquiez
est la présidente de la région ile de
france parle également de la nécessité
de la reconstruction sont des
républicains reconstruire sur une ligne
d'ouverture et de rassemblement le
souhait de pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
l'élu salue également le choix de
laurent wauquiez il a pris une décision
courageuse affirment perdre pierre
bédier à la mesure de l'échec des
républicains aux européennes
autre réaction celle d'at manas roux
président du groupe l'est républicain à
la région ile-de-france le conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes et
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaite
qu'une nouvelle ligne politique claire
soit défini au sein du parti et que
toute alliance avec le rassemblement
national soit écartée il était lundi
de nos confrères de bfm tv après la
décision de renvoyer on sait pas encore
si les choses vont donner la réalité est
simple faut que tout le monde se mette
autour de la table et donc j'imagine que
le bureau politique va être convoqué
mais moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il
y ait un congrès quelque chose qui
permet de refonder complètement les
choses mais encore une fois au terme
d'un vrai travail de fond dont l'art est
aussi une ligne politique claire qui
rappelle par exemple qu on est favorable
à l'initiative privée à l'économie de
marché
enfin rappelle notre attachement à la
baisse de la dépense publique qui est
peut-être l'un des angles morts des
manuels macron et puis aussi notre refus
absolu de toute alliance avec le front
national en france la maladie concerne
environ 9000 personnes par an la
leucémie touche aussi de nombreux
enfants et adolescents depuis samedi et
jusqu'au 8 juin ce sont les journées
nationales contre la leucémie de
nombreux événements se déroulent dans
l'hexagone l'hexagone dont quelques-uns
dans les yvelines pour en parler parce
qu'elle halte sur ce plateau avec moi
bonsoir bonsoir grégory vous êtes jeu de
par votre accueil
merci de votre présence alors vous êtes
le président de l'association cent pour
sang la vie elle organise ses journées
nationales c'est d'ailleurs la sixième
édition cette année
quel est l'objectif de cet événement de
l'équipe vous l'avez rappelé et bien sûr
d'informer de sensibiliser le grand
public puisque c'est une maladie bien
que rare qui est quand même assez
fréquentes chez les enfants le petit le
nourrisson comme l'adolescent sous sa
forme aiguë et sous sa forme chronique
chez l'adulte pour le senior au delà au
delà de 45 ans c'est une maladie qui se
soigne de mieux en mieux qui se soigne
bien puisque chez l'enfant on arrive à
des taux de guérison même s'il faut
toujours les prendre avec prudence et
j'aime pas parler de deux tours dans
dans les aspects humains de l'ordre de
85 % et chez l'adulte c'est nettement
moins mais ce qu'il faut souligner c'est
deux choses d'abord les traitements sont
longs et lourds des chimiothérapies
c'est au moins non traitement puis après
la longue attente un des cinq ans pour
être sûr d'être en état de guérison et
le deuxième point important c'est
l'avènement de gros progrès en surtout
en matière de d'immunothérapie ce que
l'on appelle la nouvelle immunothérapie
qui a tant fait de l'ingénierie
cellulaire des globules blancs et qui
permet d'aider oil qui autorise des
résultats spectaculaires
aujourd'hui cette recherche progresse
contre la maladie la recherche a
toujours progressé
elle a débuté je lisais les archives ya
pas tellement en temps quand même des
1730 un parent français joseph loto qui
avait identifié les premiers le premier
les globules blancs et ensuite 19e 20e
siècle n'a cessé de progresser dans les
années juste après la seconde guerre
mondiale l'arrivée des chimiothérapies
moderne
après de longs travaux de scientifiques
de professeurs pour en termes de
cliniques d'adapter les molécules qui
était favori ce qui était fait pour les
adultes aux enfants et depuis les années
2010 2012 on a aussi le vu l'avènement
de chimiothérapie orale spécifique des
traitements ciblés ce que l'on appelle
en termes un peu scientifique
les emmy débiteur de tyrosine kinase qui
bloque en fait le mécanisme de le semo
génèse est-ce que c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir l'espoir
qu'un jour cette maladie soit
définitivement battues ou alors non
seulement un peu mais on le doit un
petit clin d'oeil à 100% la vie quand
cette association a été créée ont guéri
c'est de l'ordre de 4 2 60% des enfants
contre 0 dans les années 60
aujourd'hui on est à 85% nous on se bat
avec d'autres un pour être à hauteur de
100% un jour et surtout 100 % pour tout
le monde et on parlait tout à l'heure de
sensibiliser pourquoi il faut
sensibiliser aujourd'hui c'est une
maladie qu'on connaît peu pourquoi il
faut sensibiliser le public
j'ai un pacs est une maladie qu'on
connaît peu moi je fais beaucoup
d'interventions dans les collèges lycées
universités il ya toujours quelques
élèves qui viennent me voir en fin
d'exposition pour d'exposer pardon pour
me parler me dire qu'ils connaissent ils
ont un ami l'année dernière un élève et
c est ça pose donc aussi la question
d'un accompagnement psychologique qu'on
met à leur disposition une cellule
psychologique pour les élèves depuis
pour le corps enseignant pour les aider
et puis c'est surtout une cause et cette
cause si vous voulez comme toutes les
causes si on n'en parle pas si on se
base sur la fin on se bat pas pour si on
ne la fait pas vivre et bien elle se
dilue dans le magma de la société il
faut en parler alors à l'occasion
notamment de ces journées nationales il
ya eu un premier week-end qui s'est
déroulée avec notamment des collectes
organisées
à sartrouville et saint-germain-en-laye
d'autres actions bien sûr partout en
france est ce que les premiers retours
sont bons sur ce premier week alors ils
sont bons ils sont humainement
extraordinaire savez c'est émouvant
d'avoir connu des gens il ya trois
quatre cinq ans qui ont perdu un proche
perdre un enfant je pas si vous voyez ce
que c'est et parfois ce sont les
grands-parents qui redynamise qui
redonne de l'espoir qu'il retire la
famille vers le haut moi j'ai eu ce
dimanche par dont j'étais à méru dans
l'oise
je salue la famille de monsieur dahan
qui a organisé sa deuxième course en la
mémoire du jeune césar décédé en 2016 à
quatre ans et qui est un succès cette
année aussi
j'ai rencontré des amis qui des
collègues chez orange que je salue aussi
tu organisé une quête au marché de saint
germain au carrefour de montesson et de
sartrouville sartrouville c'était le
week-end dernier montesson ça sera le
week-end prochain
enfin de fil en aiguille c'est tout un
réseau d'amitiés de bonne volonté qui se
dressent qui se nouent et c'est très
important et c'est chaleureux il faut
continuer de se mobiliser ça c'est très
important
vous le disiez une collecte est
organisée samedi prochain c'est au
carrefour montesson de 10h à 19h30
je salue le directeur monsieur simon
fourreaux qui nous fait confiance pour
une nouvelle année
et puis il ya toujours la possibilité de
faire un don en ligne sur http www
securitecivile point org avec le site de
votre association qui s'affiche
justement un mot pour terminer sur votre
association sang pour sang la vie qui
organise ces journées nationales quel
est votre action tout au long de l'année
justement contre cette maladie qu'est la
leucémie on n'a qu'à type d'action comme
toutes les associations de cet
écosystème
le premier c'est bien sûr de
l'information de la sensibilisation pour
tout ce qui est don de moelle osseuse
s'inscrit fichier de donneurs c'est
important quand on dans certains
traitements il est indispensable de
trouver un donneur de moelle osseuse
pour une greffe
on a plusieurs associations qui
gravitent autour de nous dont ensemble à
sucy en brie et puis la coordination
françois l'histoire donc on fait des
manifestations pour trouver pour
enregistrer des jeunes donneurs qu'ils
soient inscrits longtemps sur les
fichiers pour le don du sang le ffs et
puis aussi participé aux financiers au
financement de la recherche de dix à
treize journées nationales
l'accompagnement psychologique on a un
cabinet à paris
rubod treillis de madame marciniak pinel
qui organise des visites à domicile pour
soutenir les familles et l'association
prend en charge les 10 premières séances
voilà pour l'essentiel et c'est journée
nationale contre la leucémie c'est
jusqu'à samedi des animations partout en
france dont cette collecte samedi c'est
au magasin et carrefour de montesson et
vous pouvez également vous l'avez dit un
pascal halte faire un don directement ça
c'est sur le site
deux cent pour sang la vie merci à vous
d'être chassés sous donc voila vous
recevez un petit bracelet journée
nationale contre la leucémie
voilà il n'y a pas de petits dons ne
rien donner un même si on a parfois on
de donner 2 euros tous ces idiots
il faut donner quelque chose parce que
ça montre son attachement et sa
solidarité à cette cause et grégory je
vous donne le premier bracelet de cette
journée ainsi que l'économie du bien si
parce que vous êtes le président de
cette association 100% la merci de votre
accueil l'action ce matin de quelques
commerçants de la rue hélène-boucher
hélène boucher et de
voisins-le-bretonneux ils ont pu
rencontrer la maire de la commune
alexandra rosetti pour lui faire part de
leurs inquiétudes sur les travaux de lax
jusqu'au 25 juin la rue très endommagée
est en réflexion un chantier en cinq
phases qui prévoit des restrictions de
circulation neuf commerces sont
concernés par ces travaux
certains de leurs propriétaires
dénoncent un manque de communication de
la mairie et de l'agglomération sur ce
chantier
il demande également que les modalités
de circulation soient revus pour ne pas
faire chuter leurs activités les propos
sont collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude un garagiste automobile qui se
voit fermer son tronçon
pendant quinze jours sens jusqu'à
maintenant d'accès possible ni pour lui
ni pour ses clients dont pour un
garagiste automobile c'est un peu
compliqué de ne pas travailler pendant
quinze jours on ne peut pas admettre
tout cas accepté que une voix soit
entièrement fermé et qu aucune
circulation ne soit possible pendant une
période donnée
la gestion des déchets nucléaires en
question un débat public se tient
jusqu'au 25 septembre dans le cadre du
plan national de gestion des matières et
déchets radioactifs selon l'andra
l'agencé nationale pour la gestion des
déchets radioactifs
un million de mètres cubes de déchets
nucléaires sont stockés en france sur
différents sites alors l'om chez
greenpeace s'est saisie de ce sujet une
grande journée de mobilisation se tient
samedi sur tout le territoire et à
versailles il y aura également une
action on en parle avec mes deux
nouveaux invités julien pellicier eric
vassallo bonsoir deux du groupe local de
greenpeace versailles alors on va parler
bien sûr cette action vous organisé
samedi
déjà pourquoi il est important pour vous
de se mobiliser sur cette question des
déchets nucléaires qu'est-ce qu'il faut
dénoncer à travers cette action alors en
face à l'ô merci merci de nous recevoir
déjà donc on se saisit de cette
opportunité du de cette discussion du
plan de gestion des matières nucléaires
pour remettre à nouveau sur la table la
problématique de la production
d'électricité par le nucléaire en france
qui est très peu lente puisque en fait
elle produit actuellement 1200 tonnes de
déchets par an
donc c'est effectivement un gros
problème et donc est ce qu'on vient
défendre nous eh ben c'est là la prise
en compte de ce débat par tous les
citoyens pour qu'ils puissent participer
à cette opportunité et prendre part pour
faire valoir leurs paroles
nous ce qu'on défend c'est que il faut
fermer le robinet des déchets et pour
fermer le robinet des déchets il faut
sortir du nucléaire
alors pourquoi c'est parce qu'il faut
arrêter de stocker tous ces déchets là
qui sont nuisibles
il faut arrêter de les transporter il
faut les comptabiliser proprement et
enfin il faut mettre fin au projet
d'enfouissement de 6 géo qui est la
solution qui est actuellement retenu par
la france tient un projet
d'enfouissement dans le département de
la meuse ses seins
d'enfouissement de ces déchets
nucléaires alors il ya un rapport
d'ailleurs vous parliez du problème au
niveau français et un rapport au niveau
mondial aussi qui a été publiée par
greenpeace en janvier il parle justement
de crise mondiale sur cette question des
déchets pourquoi pourquoi parler de deux
crises mondiales qu'elles seront
finalement les conclusions de ce rapport
en fait on n'est pas le seul pays
concerné par un projet d'enfouissement
en france est effectivement cigéo il n'a
pas encore vu le jour je suis un petit
rappel et il est en discussion cette
année en 2019 et alstom pour sa salade
cohésion il ya un débat public sur cette
question mais il faut savoir que dans
d'autres pays comme les etats-unis la
suède ou l'allemagne
il ya déjà eu en application des projets
d'enfouissement qui ont abouti à des
échecs et ses projets sur une suspension
donc cette pro matic n'est pas liée
uniquement au parc nucléaire français
mais au parc au niveau mondial et toute
la population s'en saisit parce que le
risque est majeur c'est un sujet très
sérieux
aujourd'hui le parc nucléaire français
il ya 58 réacteurs sur le territoire
français selon vous aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de solution satisfaisante pour gérer
ses déchets il ya une saturation des
installations qui est qui gère ces
déchets qui est qui les stocks alors non
il n'y a pas de ce type de solution
satisfaisante puisque les matériaux
usagés qui sont mis en dépôt
suite à leur utilisation pour produire
de l'énergie par les centrales restent
toxiques
l'un ce sont des produits radioactifs
donc tant qu'on n'en produira on aura à
gérer le problème de stockage ou de mise
à l'écart de ces ressources et la
politique c'est quelque part 1 1
un mauvais cadeau qu'on legs aux
générations futures qui vont pouvoir
porter enfin qu'ils vont devoir porter
pendant des centaines et des centaines
et des centaines d'années alors pour se
saisir de ce sujet la gestion des
déchets nucléaires est aussi le rendre
accessible au public greenpeace france a
lancé une carte inter interactive et je
vais y arriver sur son site internet
pour connaître la présence des déchets
nucléaires près de chez vous alors selon
cette carte en tapant par exemple
versailles sur cette carte on constate
qu'il ya autour de la ville plusieurs
transit de ces déchets nucléaires on
nous rappelle aussi la présence du cea à
saclay qui a plusieurs activités liées
au nucléaire la présence aussi d'une
ancienne décharge de déchets radioactifs
le but de la démarche quel est-il c'est
justement d'informer le grand public sur
cette question
alors effectivement je pense que la
population est largement sous informée
du problème
malgré les nombreuses consultations
qu'ils aient eu par le passé je pense
qu'elle leur ampleur n'a pas été
suffisante
aujourd'hui s'il ya une bonne action que
fait le gouvernement de lancer un débat
greenpeace est là pour appuyer cette
action là de façon locale et de façon
floue plémentaires en soumettant ces
informations sous forme de cartes
sachant que tout le territoire est
concerné je pense que beaucoup de la
population de prendre un pour cent de la
population ne sait pas qui sont à
proximité soit d'un lieu de stockage
nucléaire sur des revenus de passage
parce que il y a beaucoup de transport
de déchets nucléaires et donc si tout
aussi dangereux qui est un lieu de
stockage
voilà donc cette carte elle est
interactif sur le web
elle sera présente
lors de la journée d'action dont nous
avons parlé mais on est dans le même
état d'esprit c'est d'informer bien sûr
le grand public c'est pour ça que vous
vous organisez que greenpeace organise
une grande journée de mobilisation à
travers toute la france tout à fait on
n'est jamais suffisamment informés donc
on est là pour s'en assurer et pour
aussi accompagner le citoyen pour aller
plus loin pour lui pour montrer qu'il ya
des actions qu'il peut faire
il peut déjà participé aux débats il
veut interpeller le ministre la
transition écologique françois de rugy
et communiquer autour de lui et aussi
changer de fournisseur d'électricité
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya d'autres
sources de production d'électricité qui
est pas y'a pas que nucléaire est aussi
gergy renouvelables on prend on promo
c'est sur ce d'électricité et en change
de fournisseur
on accompagne cette transition là alors
donc je rappelle que c'est juste prévu
samedi cette action à versailles est ce
que des événements de ce genre sur la
protection de la planète est ce que vous
avez un succès attire toujours plus de
monde
est ce que les les français les
yvelinois sont davantage mobilisés sur
ces questions on a vu plusieurs
centaines de personnes la semaine
dernière pour une marche pour le climat
à saint quentin en yvelines et les
français les yvelinoises se saisissent
davantage de ces sujets on l'a encore vu
à l'occasion des élections européennes
on pense qu'il ya un climat qui est
particulièrement qui rend
particulièrement sensible les gens à la
question de l'environnement des jeunes
voyous place d'europe écologie les verts
mais on a vu que ses questions étaient
en tout cas intéressé les français tout
à fait et nous on le vit au travers de
l'animation de notre groupe local on
voit de plus en plus de gens venir à nos
réunions demandé d'être acteur du
changement et voulant prendre part à la
défense de l'environnement donc là il ya
vraiment une prise de conscience
collective
c'est clair c'est indéniable un mot pour
terminer sur votre groupe local combien
de membres mais de combien de membres
est il composé quel type d'action vous
organisés tout au long de l'année
alors il ya une attitude d'action moi
j'ai qu'une entité d'un an
eric pourra compléter mes propos
on a va dire qu'on est entre 50 et 100
membres sur le groupe local uniquement
avec sigh il ya locales et nos
interventions sont diverses et variées
on accompagne la direction qu'une piste
france l'a aujourd'hui c'est une
nucléaire après il y aura d'autres
actions dont la visibilité est plutôt à
eric et complète les on arrive à la fin
de cet entretien dans tout cas la
prochaine action c'est ce samedi à
versailles on peut avoir toutes les
informations sur le site de greenpeace
versailles en tout cas sur la nappe âge
greenpeace versailles aussi un hashtag
qui est mis en place et cette journée
hashtag zéro déchet nucléaire vous
pouvez retrouver toutes les informations
nécessaires au sujet des actions que va
mener greenpeace au travers de la france
et on invite tout le monde à relayer
toutes les actions qu'on va poster sur
twitter et facebook pour les partager et
faire passer l'info est lui en a parlé
aussi sur le site de greenpeace vous
pouvez trouver une lettre ouverte à
françois de rugy notre ministre de la
transition écologique et vous pouvez
utiliser cette lettre ouverte pour
l'interpeller sur le changement
nécessaire elle rappelé à ses
engagements
quand il n'était pas encore ministre
mais vous à d'autres fonctions merci à
eric vassallo merci également à vous
julien pellicier je rappelle que vous
êtes du groupe local de greenpeace à
versailles le sport et du football
dernière ligne droite pour la coupe du
monde féminine en france l'événement
s'ouvre ce vendredi au parc des princes
avec le match france corée du sud les
bleus avec un e se prépare actuellement
dans les yvelines à clairefontaine un
entraînement était ouvert ce matin aux
enfants venus notamment de croissy sur
seine le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros ils ont fait beaucoup de bruit
plus de 400 jeunes venus principalement
de croissy sur seine se sont rendus ce
lundi matin à clairefontaine pour un
entraînement de l'équipe de france
féminine
un rendez vous programmé quatre jours
seulement avant leur premier match de
coupe du monde
j'aime bien
rial et les bleus c'est bien sûr on les
voit pas tous les jours
c'est les professionnels allez les bleus
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on peut y
voir c'est
moi c'est des joueurs professionnels
c'est ben hassine ces magnifiques thèmes
donne envie de devenir peau de dejan
villes sélectionnées par la fifa
croissy-sur-seine recevra les bleus
pendant la coupe du monde pour créer
l'effervescence la commune a pas hésité
à affréter plusieurs bus pour emmener
des jeunes à la session d'avoir la joie
d'avoir des enfants heureux c'est pour
ça qu'on l'a accueilli l'équipe de
france c'est pour transmettre ses
valeurs de ce sport et d'amour et de
joie quand on trouve ici dans un stade
après les tribunes direction les
terrains la matinée s'est terminée par
une séance de dédicaces avec les
joueuses tous ont voulu un souvenir de
cette journée de la compétition approche
plus plus agrandi pour iliad
effervescence au coeur c'est bien pour
nous ce positif les enfants ils sont
pleins d'énergie donc on en prend c'est
bien à lire ça fait plaisir
en plus il ya beaucoup d'enfants et
c'est vrai qu'à notre âge en bas on
rêvait quoi de ça une belle surprise ce
matin après avoir rencontré les jeunes
de croissy sur seine les bleus fouleront
pour la première fois la pelouse du
stade omnisports de la ville ce jeudi
six joueurs pour un entraînement à huis
clos avant leur premier match contre la
corée du sud et à quelques jours de
l'ouverture du mondial le district des
yvelines organisait samedi une journée
entièrement dédiée au football féminin
une trentaine d' équipes du département
il ya participé manifestation la fois
sportive et festive puisque trois
finales départementales se sont joués
dans l'après midi le retour avec
marylène iapichino et aurélien 11
ces jeunes footballeuses de l'usb y ont
cours viennent de remporter la coupe des
yvelines dans la catégorie u16 depuis
quelques années maintenant le district
du département organise une journée
dédiée au football féminin
quand on faisait les finales garçons en
même temps que les finales filles balaie
le public aller vers les finales garçons
et filles avait personne devant les
finales fils un jour on a décidé que les
finales filles se passerait en tant que
tel
justement pour en faire et à quelques
jours du lancement du mondial féminin de
football
les élus moyse ont démontré qu'elle
n'avait plus rien à prouver sur le
terrain parce que parce que il n'ya pas
que les garçons qui peuvent gagner
merci les filles et on est aussi
complète que les garçons en plus de
trois finales départementales des
animations étaient proposées toute la
journée au public il ya cinq ans le
département des yvelines comptait neuf
cent soixante douze joueuses
aujourd'hui elles sont 2181 manimba non
plus je pense que les parents ont pu
commencer à découvrir le foot féminin et
et mieux comment dire le comprendre
parce qu'effectivement les filles au
foot et ben c'est pas toujours évident
pour les parents là je pense que ça
commence à se démocratiser donc c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt bien
c'est dans la bonne ambiance en plus y'a
pas le football masculin
surtout à ce niveau là c'est ces petits
beaucoup plus violent froidure autre
chose et pour clôturer cette journée
l'équipe féminine senior de trappes
l'emporter sans but they de sa carrière
sur scène et qui dit sport dit forcément
michael est le nid d'eurobonds soir
concert qu'a duré l'entretien pour tv 78
comme chaque lundi vos résultats
sportifs en vous nous livrer les
résultats sportifs du week-end pâques du
football y avait aussi du handball c'est
ça plaisir s'est fait plaisir pour sa
dernière journée en nationale 3 les
plaisirs aux a déjà assuré de descendre
l'année prochaine on prenait un jeu
offensif face à stella sport se sont
finalement imposés sur le score de 32 à
26 une victoire qui n'aura aucune
conséquence au classement plaisir
termine 10ème sur 12 équipes
il n'aura manqué qu'un point aux joueurs
de victor guerrier pour se maintenir
mais bien de la saison 6 victoires 4
nuls et 12 défaites
rendez vous l'année prochaine en
prénationale direction à présent
montigny le bretonneux toujours handball
mais cette fois ci chez les féminines
dans le championnat de nationale 2 monti
le bretonneux n'a pu faire mieux que
match nul sur le terrain de stella sport
saint maur ce samedi soir score final 28
à 28 un résultat qui n'a aucune
conséquence au classement
esi montagne coachée par donischal et de
terminer une décevante huitième place à
13 points du podium et 11 défaites
concédées ont pesé dans la balance
on parle maintenant baseball nickel en
première division les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux jouer ce week-end
la 9e journée du championnat contre les
commerces de metz et lazy montant
remporté la première partie sur le score
de 16 à 0 mais se sont fait surprendre
le second match ils ont perdu 10 à 7 les
cougars reste deuxième de la poule b
avec un bilan de 12 victoires pour 6
défaites et ils sont toujours qualifiés
pour les playoffs de fin de saison leur
prochain match est programmé le 16 juin
prochain à domicile contre le puc de
paris sinon sports collectifs sports de
ballon on termine par du basket
l'entente le chesnay versailles a connu
un week end magique les seniors se sont
imposés face à à paris en finale de
playoffs de prénationale sur le score de
92 à 60
vous avez bien entendu 92 à 60 le match
s'est déroulé sur terrain neutre dans un
final fort à palaiseau résultat qui leur
permet de monter en nationale 3 la
saison prochaine
une
historique merci michael et l'entente le
chesnay-versailles que vous allez
recevoir dans votre émission le 7-8
sport c'est dans quelques minutes assure
tv soixante dix huit ça ne vous a pas
échappé 1 ce week-end la chaleur et le
soleil se sont fait attendre il était de
retour en tout cas ce week-end certains
en ont profité pour se rafraîchir avec
la montée des températures est les
températures au delà des 30 degrés l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
proposait notamment des jeux d'eau aux
visiteurs patrick jacques de dixmude et
nicolas d'andré
[Musique]
il a fait beau il a fait chaud durant
les premiers jours du mois de juin à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
le parc a fait le plein près de trente
cinq mille visiteurs pour le samedi 1er
et dimanche 2 juin enfin l'été est
arrivé au 1er juin et donc ce week-end
nous avons eu notre premier vrai
week-end de saison avec une affluence
exceptionnelle par rapport à ce que nous
avons connu là au mois de mai avec des
températures autour des 30 degrés les
jeux d'eau ont eu beaucoup de succès
serpent aoki signer fontaine parents et
enfants ont pu en profiter pour se
rafraîchir les enfants vis-à-vis chevaux
là on cherchait un endroit où se
rafraîchir aux beignets et dupont est
venu s'y promener au bord du lac
on a mangé on fait un tri clic et montre
en est ici on va un peu s'amuser avec le
p tit mais les enfants ont aussi répondu
aux questions de notre journaliste et
n'ont pas hésité à la rosée et alors que
tu fais avec monsieur aulas a way s'est
pas montré
montrer comme ça et pendant ce temps là
j'en prends plein aussi c'est pas mal
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]